are we on for a December election it
looks like it the government ready to go
they're not the only ones
down at labor HQ the top team pleased as
punch this election apparently their
victory we're going out there to fight
an election campaign and I can't wait to
get out there on the streets in every
town and village in this country labor
will be there giving a message of real
hope where this government offers
nothing but in truth Jeremy Corbyn
bounced into this election labour the
last major party to back a Christmas
poll many in his shadow cabinet didn't
want to take Boris Johnson's bait but
now time to put on a united front yes
absolutely absolutely yeah now everybody
is absolutely up for this also up for it
the Prime Minister jumping out of his
seat as he implored MPs to back his
election vote we are left with no choice
but to go to the country to break free
from this impasse and to allow us all to
submit as we must in all humility to the
judgement of the electorate three times
he's failed to get the election he
craves locked in place by MPs afraid of
no deal but the blockage in Parliament
finally clearing the PM released from
his trap the Liberal Democrats in the
SNP want a brexit election to the eyes
to the right 438 the nose to the left 20
confirmation then from the Commons but
reaction muted MPs on all sides could
now face losing their jobs the PM
straight off to work
rallying his MPs at their weekly meat
and the Lib Dem leader straight out of
the blocks I am taking my message to the
country I'm standing as a candidate for
Prime Minister and in these volatile
political times that is absolutely
possible I will set no limit for my
ambitions for the Liberal Democrats and
for our country
because our country deserves better than
what we have had from those tired old
labour and conservative party this
conservative Minister more cautious but
can't see any other way out
unfortunately it is Parliament that has
forced the primaries hand into having an
extension and not approve the necessary
legislation wouldn't have the
opportunity to do so this is all deeply
unsatisfactory I firmly believe in our
parliamentary democracy and and you know
we would much rather not be having to
have this election but it is happening
three and a half years since a
referendum two years since the last
general election and on the heels of
three brexit delays Parliament has
finally decided it can't resolve brexit
here it's time to go back to the people
via the ballot box to see if a majority
can be found for leave or remain in what
could be the most important general
election since the Second World War the
first December general election in
nearly a century perhaps a fitting end
to a year of political division the PM
getting his head down but his thumbs up
this election will be make-or-break for
Boris Johnson and for brexit 2bath Rick
B Sky News Westminster